William suspended by the league for the
2006 season after a fourth violation and
decision to quit stunned his teammates
infuriated his fans we all would like to
see Ricky Williams back on the field but
who knows if we ever will again I'm very
regretful that people were hurt in the
process of me doing that and and I do
realize that it - a lot of people it
comes off as being very very selfish
Ricky Williams the Heisman winning
running back who sent multiple rushing
records for the Miami Dolphins was
suspended by the NFL and then retired
under a cloud of shame in 2003 his
offense testing positive for marijuana
Miami Dolphins fans the media and the
NFL all turned on Williams villainizing
him as a troublemaker with a drug
problem
Williams ultimately returned and played
several more seasons in the NFL but the
stigma never went away but when if the
league in the public were wrong to judge
Ricky Williams what if he was just ahead
of his time here at the 420 Games in
Santa Monica runners lined up to race
against the stereotype of the lazy
stoner
Ricky Williams is in attendance as is
former New Orleans Saints tight end at a
Lee Williams my coach hat is saying he
said the only day you're gonna fill
hundred percent as a first day training
camp as a former player I've seen 90 to
95% of athletes smoke both men are here
representing the gridiron cannabis
coalition a group dedicated to promoting
the benefits of medical marijuana in
athletics Rickey is one of many NFL
players voicing concerns about the
misuse of opioids in the locker room
that was my big revelation I was sitting
in the training room one day and I just
watched player after player come in to
take take a torte off shot just to
practice like many Americans suffering
from chronic pain he's hoping the league
will consider another alternative I
realize if we have to take all this
medication all these pharmaceuticals
just just in practice I can't be good
for our bodies in the long run and
that's when I started to look at my
house seriously and look for
alternatives but cannabis is a banned
substance under the NFL Players
agreement a rule that went into effect
in the 1980s during the height of the
drug war it is still an illegal
substance on a national basis we'll
continue to follow the medicine our
experts right now are not indicating
that we should change our policy in any
way but because marijuana is an illegal
drug getting research approved can be a
long and timely process so former NFL
players are putting up their own money
to get around the government's tight
regulations and fund their own research
cannabis has been in the closet it's
been suppressed it's coming out konstanz
Finley who runs the cannabis extract
firm Constance therapeutics is one of
the researchers hoping to produce the
evidence players need to change NFL
policy we want to help the cannabis the
gridiron cannabis coalition inform and
and further medicinal cannabis being
used with athletes I think that if the
owners had a chance to see serious
science-based results outside of
dispensary medical marijuana actually
seeing this plant being taken seriously
that we could give the owners a chance
to change their minds in a realistic way
some researchers are finding evidence
CBD and THC have two major benefits for
athletes they act as a non-addictive
pain reliever and they can protect the
brain from injury these healing
properties should be of interest to a
league where addiction to painkillers
and concussions have become major issues
those drugs that they give you like
vicodin if they subscribe they high
amount dosage to you you don't have any
control over yourself and you feel like
you're out of body Washington University
researchers found that former NFL
players used opioids at a rate more than
four times that of the normal population
and found that 71% of them misused the
drugs at some point in time there is a
broad movement towards respecting
athletes as the professionals that they
are as opposed to kind of looking at
them as a cog that you plug into
something to make money it isn't just
the NFL player it's like the women
Hockey League they have so many head
injuries right the bicyclists who fall
and hurt their heads there's lots of
ways this could go in and the NFL could
be a leader as opposed to you know the
block players like Ricky and Eddie Lee
Williams are hoping their participation
in these studies can lead to change and
help future athletes stay healthy long
after their playing days are over
hopefully as public opinion starts to
change the league's most often their
stance and and hopefully I think
especially the NFL they could really be
ahead of the charge as far as getting
this medicine to people really wouldn't
it be great if the NBA and the NFL and
other professional sports organizations
accepted the validity of the science and
the experience of their players there's
this marvelous plant that with regular
use could really truly minimize that
damage that's a beautiful story
you